Miss Universe 2015 is oh man those are
words Steve Harvey will regret saying
forever and is the biggest blunder and
beauty pageant history calling out the
wrong winner because the real winner of
Miss Universe was Miss Philippines Pia
wurtzbach and Michelle Turner just spoke
with her today in New York what you have
to say Michelle well Nancy as you can
imagine this hasn't been easy for either
of these ladies and actually just this
past weekend
miss Colombia stirred up a little more
controversy when she called the blender
a quote great injustice so I had to ask
Pia what she thought about that do you
think it was an injustice I understand
if she feels that way if the situation
was the other way around I think I would
feel the same way I think that my
supporters would feel the same way as
well
I have to apologize ariana gutierrez
Miss Colombia went on to tell a Columbia
radio station that the experience was
quote very humiliating for me you know
what I understand she was hurting and I
was also concerned for her as she saw
this tonight what would you want to say
to her I hope that she realizes that
this will open doors for her and I think
that she will go far I know it hurts
weighing in was Donald Trump who until
recently was co-owner of the pageant do
I think I'd make him a pole winner would
be very cool what you thought about that
I think that it would be a challenge for
two girls to share a crowd it's never
been done before and speaking of that
crown he let me in on a little secret
do you sleep with the crown on you did
okay no fun but beside yeah I've done it
I have to admit I'm sorry guys do you
have a celebrity crush yeah I James
Franco is really really now look I told
her James just might be watching this
but she says if she can't get a date
with him she also likes Seth Rogen and
Tatom even though they are both taken
now Pia has been acting since she was 11
years old and she still does have
Hollywood aspirations in fact she says
her dream is to become a fun what do you
think about that Nancy oh I think that a
lot of people are pulling for her to get
her wishes considering what happened
alright Michelle thank you very much